Hi, my name is Satyajeet Salgar.
I work in Google Search.
Thanks for watching.
I'm going to tell you a little
bit about the Knowledge Graph
and how using schema.org
markup, we, Google,
and you developers
and content owners
can work together to build a
better experience for people
around media.
But first, let's talk
about why this matters.
It matters because life is hard.
There's always a lot to do.
Everything is harder
than it needs to be.
And most things are unfair.
But some things make
it a little bit better.
One of those things are
movies and television.
If you're a fan like me, it's
an important part of your life.
And most people are like me.
According to
official statistics,
literally the only
thing people do more
than watch television is sleep.
We at Google see this in what
people ask us about every day
as well.
But finding great
content to watch
is actually getting harder.
And there are a
number of reasons why.
The main reason
is fragmentation.
There's just more
content being created.
The amount of content
that's being created
has exploded, as have
the ways to distribute
that content and the
business models tied to it.
Do you rent, or do you buy?
Do you watch HD or SD?
Do you have access through
your cable provider?
Is there a window after
which this movie will
be open on another service?
Finally, do you watch
this on your phone?
Can you watch it on TV?
Will this be on broadcast
television at some point?
So basically something that
would make life less hard
has become a hard problem.
But let's solve
that hard problem,
and let's do it together.
First, let's break this
problem down a little bit.
Let's talk about
three things and help
people solve these three.
What are the various things
that these people could watch?
Where should they
consider watching it?
And why should they
Now let's talk
about the tools we
have available to
us to help them.
In particular, let's talk about
the Google Knowledge Graph.
The Knowledge Graph maps
out how 1 billion things
in the real world-- 1 billion
things-- people, places,
and things-- are
connected to each other.
Having this data in
a structured form
lets us do some really
powerful things with it.
It helps us answer all
sorts of hard questions
every single day.
For example, just ask
Google a celebrity's age,
or compare two entities
like rivers or two movies,
or ask at Google who won
the Oscars a certain year.
Today, we answer questions
like a movie's running time,
its cost, and so much more.
We can answer some really
hard questions as well.
For example, how many
degrees of separation
is your favorite actor
from Kevin Bacon?
Or what movies have
two actors you've
heard about been in together?
Just try this out.
Now let's go back and
tackle those questions
we wanted to answer,
starting with helping
you decide what to watch.
Try searching for action movies,
or even movies about basketball
on an Android phone.
You'll see an entry point into
a rich, immersive experience.
You can browse a list
of movies, click through
to learn more
about one you like,
learn everything about
it, as well as check out
a magically organized list of
recommended similar movies.
We think this experience of
organized Knowledge Panels
will help you explore movies and
TV shows you never heard about
and make it a lot more fun.
Now let's go to that
second question--
where should you watch it?
The most obvious thing we
could do at Google to help you
with that is give you a link
right on the Knowledge Panel
to click on when you're
looking at a piece of content.
So we've done that
most obvious thing.
For numerous
episodes and movies,
we're trying hard to give
you a single click that'll
let you either watch or
buy that piece of content.
We want to partner
with you to make
sure we let people watch
every single piece of content
every creator ever created
with a single click.
Now let's talk about why
someone watches something.
Now, there are many
things that help
you decide if you're
going to watch--
what the trailer of
a movie looks like,
who's in it, who the director
is and what they did before.
We try hard to give you all of
that information on the Google
Knowledge Panel.
Now, another important factor
is what critics you like
and trusted voices also think
about that piece of content.
So we made it easier to
surface critic reviews right
on Google Knowledge Panels.
Try it out for
some recent movies.
We've actually found
that people are
able to make better
decisions because of this.
They tell us it gives
them more nuance
as well as introduces them to
new critics whose opinions they
really enjoy.
Now, we're starting
with movies, but we
believe the pattern will carry
over to all media-- for books,
for TV shows, games, music.
In fact, we're inviting you to
submit critic reviews for books
as well.
Stay tuned as we extend
this to other verticals.
So hopefully the question
at this point is,
what's in it for me as a
developer or content owner,
and how hard is this to do?
Now not only do we believe
this creates a better
experience for
people, we think it's
a great way for people to find
your content-- your videos
or your reviews--
and get introduced
to your app, your
website, or your service.
By simply adding a couple of
lines of schema.org markup
on your site, you can ensure
that Google finds and surfaces
these links on search,
on desktop, as well as
on the web and mobile.
So what I want to
leave you with.
We're expanding beyond our
set of initial partners.
Join us.
It's easy to do.
And it's a great
way to help people
find your app or service.
Check out developers.google.com
to learn more.
Let's build a better
media experience
and help people make
better decisions
about what they watch.
Thanks for making a great
decision and watching this far.
[MUSIC PLAYING]